Wow!
Hey, it's Pewdiepie! the best youtuber ever, I have the most subscribers , so that's how it works. STFU
Today we're going to talk about streaming
streaming "fails" (laugh)
The thing that I love about uhh
stream fails
Specifically is because it doesn't matter if it's one frame
Okay, one frame you fuck up, it's on the internet forever, and you're going to get shit for it
Now I have never made that mistake before I would never be that fucking stupid
* pewds being disgusting *
that I would do something dumb like
accidentally showing my porn history in a video
Mission failed
First one. I love this video. I love this video so much. It's one of my favorite. It's this fucking
streamer who gets caught for
Using Wallhack and some other hacks as she said playing with a hack without knowing that
the stream actually sees her using the hack
Pewds: and let's just watch. Girl: Stop shooting. P: Oh wow okay. What is that?
You motherfucker (what a dumbass)
*Watches a fellow sister fister play*
Girl: Motherfucker!
She's not actually hacking. She's just so good at the game that she can automatically see the health bar and through Walls
this is
Women for you, they are so good at games
They can't help it
*girl screaming*
That's right. Why did you reload? that was the issue there I think uh
Girl: I don't, man
Thank you very much though. Welcome to the Dumpling Empire
My name is Miss Q Gemini.
Pewds: The dumpling empire, one of my -it really hurts for me to break down this footage because I
Myself used to be part of the dumpling empire
My favorite Empire to be part of, the dumpling empire
Girl: We're -we're trying to not be a noob
We're trying to not be a noob
by using wall hacks! (laugh)
The self deprecation! "I am trying not to be a noob, even though I am kind of good at this game"
because you are using fucking wall hack.
How dishonest can you be collecting donations?
from people
Simultaneously, just fucking cheating up the game
I-It's so annoying to me when people cheat in games 'cause okay, okay. You know what I'll take that back
I sort of respect cheating in games if you just want to fuck people over, you know? Want to upset, them piss them off I
Can sort of understand that, but when you just cheat to pretend that you're good, that's just fucking stupid. Oh, that's just cringy, man
I can't-I can't stand beside the dumpling army any longer for that.
(yelling)
But my favourite bit is when she realized she got caught, and she tries to blame it on her friend (laugh)
(screaming)
Look at her face. Oh!
Girl: Yo, you guys, um, do you guys ever get that weird glitch in CSGO. (Pewds mocking): Yo, you guys ever get that weird glitch in CSGO.
Where you see through the walls for two fucking rounds and don't acknowledge it
But then all the sudden you do? (laugh)
Girl: ...where it shows your rank. It shows everyone's rank.
P: Oh, it shows everyone's rank! G: I played the other day, P: Uh-huh! G: I played the other day with
Pewds: You played the other day
Girl: With (?), and he had it and now I have it
I don't- I don't know what's wrong
Pewds: It must have been some sort of computer virus that installed itself and then you just didn't see it!
Girl: That's weird
Pewds: That's weird, that is weird.
Girl: (yell) Wait! What the fuck!?
Pewds (mocking):  (yell) What the fuck?
Okay. Well, what's excuse number two? Please tell me.
Girl: Clara?!
Pewds: Clara (laugh)
Fucking Clara. I've been telling you guys about her for so long. Fucking Clara cannot be trusted
What does she do?
Girl: Hold on. Clara, give me one second.
Pewds: All right
Girl: Where is this? How do I close this? Yo, Rock, I need some help because I don't know what I'm looking at right now.
What the fuck is that. Hello??
I need to text my friend Clara right now. She was at my house earlier today. What the actual fuck?!
I love the top comment under this video. Clara, "sorry"
(laugh)
Yo, Rock. Do you remember- do you remember when fucking Clara got the fucking VAC ban? I'm going to kill this girl.
She promised me she didn't use it on the PC. I am fucking done.
She was here today, and I was watching her
Why the fuck- why the fuck?! This is what happens when you let people use your PC. Can't trust them. Alright
That's such- so mean to Clara. Like this fucking girl
Girl: I think uhhhh- I think this is it. I'm going to uhhhh
Pewds: It's so fucking- Oh my God
Girl: I'm going to log off now
So one of my nightmares with streaming is that you would accidentally leave the stream on, and then uh you do something horrible
Somethin you're not supposed to do, something not Christian
and uh everyone sees it, but this girl clearly
fakes. That- that- that's the case and it's so fucking obvious when you look it- look at it.
Girl: But yeah, I think uhhhhh
I think this is it. I'm going to
Pewds (mocking): Yeah, I think this is it! I am going to go away now!
Girl: To uh
I'm going to log off now and
(Pewds laughing)
Have a- Nicely gonna have a good night's sleep
Pewds (mocking): I am going to go away! I am going to have a nice sleepy and nothing else!
I will go and sleep!
Mmah
No! Not continue streaming, and no masturbating!
Girl: In time, hopefully uh, you guys
will be here-
Yeah.
Pewds:  Wait I just realized this video
Got age-restricted so that means if I show what's about to happen
My video will be age restricted and fuck that, you can look it up yourself. She comes back. She plays her fiddle
Okay, uh but it's not only the women of course. We g- (laugh) this is also a classic
This one didn't get age-restricted though. It's uh
It's just funny when he- when- when guys does it
Guy: What is up, everyone?
Hello, hello and welcome (snort)
Oh the cameras on
(laugh)
Ba deh beh beh beh
Cue the Seinfeld
(laugh)
(mocking) Oh the cameras! How long have you been watching? Did you see all of that?
But you know, streaming isn't that bad. It's not like actually bad things happen. Wait. Home invasions caught on Twitch
What? Where do people live? Jesus Christ.
Girl: Oh! The hell?
(guy shouting in background)
Pewds: Jesus. Oh my God
This music is fucking awesome
Anyone know what song this is?
Really like this tune
Really good
I'm joking. I hope she's okay. I think she is. I- she made a video about it afterwards
Girl: At the time
I didn't know what was going on. They were supposed to go to someone else, like their target.
They were probably after a youtuber
They make more money.
Guy: I have a gun right now, that was actually really close.
And our car speeds off. A car
just sped off. I think my neighbors just got driven by. Y'know
Let me- let me go check actually. Hold on. I might need to grab a gun just in case but I think it's just a drive-by
They see where my knife at yo. Let me get a knife.
Other guy: I think it's just a drive-by. No big deal.
This- this clip kind of annoys me
Maybe because I don't- I don't know exactly what is happening, but there's some drive-by, hear some gunshots
And he's "like let me just get my knife, let me just get my gun"
Has this nibba not heard of swatting? Okay. Police comes in and you have a gun you're gonna get fucking shot
That seems like a terrible idea to have a gun next to you when you fucking stream
(stuttering)
Right? Am I the only one thinking like this? So there's this audio clip
That sounds exactly like someone is knocking on your door if you have headphones on it will trick you
100% So it knocks here, and then you obviously do this and you look there
and then it goes in this ear a little less. So it really sounds like something is coming from there, like it sounds super real and
Some people send these to streamers, and it tricks them (laugh) and the reaction is just fucking hilarious
(knocking)
It sounds real
Other guy: God! And then they just fucking hide
Pewds: But nibba this guy, just grabs a gun in hi- (stuttering) If I had a gun next to me
I'd throw it the fuck away, I'm like, I'm not- THAT'S NOT MINE !!!!!
Look, how casu- why does everyone just have guns? Fuck, man!
Do you want to get shot? I don't get it, man.
Other guy: Oh, and he's dead.
Guy streaming: You got- Ohh, you son of a bitch.
Pewds (mocking): Oh, you got me
(laugh)
What the fuck?
Look at it. He's got a gun next to him! Dude, you're streamer !!
You can't do that with the fucking- (laugh) (sigh) I don't know why bothers me
Did you not see what happened to this dude?
News guy: First at 11:00 (?) on your side
Exclusive
Both: Shot between the eyes
News: And a mistaken police response! It's an alarming new Crime trend in our area
Jesus Christ, man. Why do I have to tell people to do it right? Oh my God this fucking thing, okay?
Let's finish with this one. This is probably one of my favorites
(laugh) Because it's so confusing
So, this streamer
I think the context here is that she was playing Dark Souls, which you can tell here by the giant window of gameplay, and
She was getting drunk but for some reason, and I can't- what I want to know why. 'Cause I don't understand why. She decided to
stream herself
walking up the stairs
in crutches
Now, (laugh) here's the thing about that that I don't understand (laugh)
First of all, seeing a girl walking up the stairs. Thi-
It's not that attractive. Okay?
It's not like I'm always like "Oh my fucking God!
I can see a little better angle of that ass", like it's not that great. Okay?
I understand the whole thing that they figured out that they can do on Twitch where they like have a whiteboard and they
bend over. They're like
(high voice) "Ooh let me put the deh there"
I can sort of understand that, but just walking up the stairs? That is not attractive, okay? It's not sexy, but the thing is (laugh)
She doesn't just walk up the stairs. She walk up the stairs in fucking crutches. That's like- (laugh) It's not sexy
You look like a fucking retard. What are you doing? Why is she doing thi- ?
(laugh)
If I came into this dream now, I'd be like, "Is that a girl in special needs? Like what's wrong with her? Is
she trying to show.. what a struggle it is to walk up the stairs when (stutter) handicap?
Is that what this is about?
How do- how does the thought go, "I'm going to put a camera here,
so that people live can watch me walk up the stairs in crutches. That- how does that make any sense?!
I don't understand! I'm so confused!
But then it keeps going!
'Cause her boyfriend, Sodapoppin, bless his soul
BF: Dude, Mia
Is this fake? It feels like I'm watching a Big Brother reality show or some shit, but I'm well entertained
so I hope it- I hope it is. He comes in super pissed about this (laugh)
(talking)
BF: Walking up these steps, your ass. Right before that, looked like you were trying to (?)
(girl arguing back)
Pewds (repeating): How was I supposed to know that?
Well, I hope they worked it through
I hope they got through whatever the fuck that was, because that can't be fun to have life. But anyway
that's just some of my favorite streaming moments. I had plenty more but I think we're out of time
We're not really out of time, but we hit the 10-minute mark
So you know, it's time for me to go and uh fuck off and play some pub G. Anyway
thank you guys for watching. Leave a like and sister fister and all that shit and I'll see you tomorrow with another video
(kiss)
Sister Fister©